hey this is presh tallwalker here's a
fun area maze puzzle
the first row has three rectangles their
areas are 21 meters squared the second
area is unknown and the third area is 43
meters squared the second and third
rectangles have a combined width of 10
meters
the second row has just one rectangle
its width spans the first two rectangles
its height is four meters and its area
is 29 meters squared you need to solve
for the unknown area which is the second
rectangle in the first row
I credit naoki Inaba who created these
wonderful area maze puzzles I read about
it on Alex bellis's column in the
guardian
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
I'll present one solution that uses
algebra and another solution that is a
creative method so let's get started
with the algebra solution
so let's say the second rectangle has a
width that's equal to X and a height
that's equal to y
since the second and third rectangles
together have a width equal to 10. the
third rectangle's width is equal to 10
minus X
our goal is to solve for the area of the
second rectangle which is equal to x
times y
now focus on the third rectangle
its area is equal to 43 meters squared
and we know its width and height
so we have 10 minus X multiplied by Y is
equal to 43. we can distribute to get 10
y minus X Y is equal to 43.
now let's focus on this rectangle with
area equal to 29 meters squared we know
that its height is equal to four so its
width will be equal to 29 over 4 which
is equal to 7.25 meters
now this spans the width of the first
two rectangles
so we can say that the first rectangle
has width that's equal to 7.25 minus X
consequently from the first rectangle we
get the equation
7.25 minus X multiplied by Y is equal to
21. this means 7.25y minus X Y is equal
to 21.
so we now have a system of two equations
subtract the second equation from the
first this will give
2.75y is equal to 22 so that Y is equal
to 8. we can substitute into the first
equation this will give 80 minus X Y is
equal to 43 so X Y is equal to 37 and
that's the answer
so now let's solve the problem in a
creative way
the first rectangle has area equal to 21
meters squared
shift this over to the third rectangle
dividing it into two rectangles we know
the total area is 43 and we've moved 21
meters squared over here so the
remaining area will be equal to 22
meters squared
now let's disappear the rectangle in the
second row and focus on this rectangle
which has dimensions of 10 by 4.
this rectangle's area will be equal to
40 meters squared now let's reappear the
29 meter squared rectangle and shift it
over to the 40 meter squared rectangle
the area that remains will be 40 minus
29 which is equal to 11 meters squared
now focus on the two rectangles on the
right hand side they have areas of 22
and 11.
both these rectangles share the same
width therefore the top rectangle must
have twice the height
so we can use this principle by
reappearing this 29 meter squared
rectangle this shares the same width
with the top two rectangles so their
combined area must be twice 29 so that
is equal to 58 meters squared now we
already know the first rectangle has
area of 21 meters squared therefore the
unknown area is 58 minus 21 which is
equal to 37 meters squared and that's
another way to solve this problem
amazing
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time